voy a hacer un par de problemas sobre
torque y fuerza especialmente porque
quizás resulta un poco confuso todo lo
que dije sobre las fuerzas que van o que
provocan una rotación en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj o
aquellas fuerzas que provocan una
rotación en dirección de las manecillas
del reloj así que voy a tratar de
hacerlo un poco más claro así que
dibujemos nuestro sube y baja ya clásico
muy bien digamos que aquí tengo este
sube y baja
ahí está y aquí está nuestro punto
pivote o nuestro fulcro o el eje de
rotación como quieran como quieran
llamarlo muy bien entonces ahí tenemos
nuestro sube y baja nuevamente y vamos a
empezar a aventar fuerzas sobre este
sobre este sube y baja así que digamos
que aquí hay una fuerza que va hacia
arriba digamos que esta es una fuerza de
10 newtons y para tener muy bien claro
que de qué o cómo va a interactuar en
este sube y baja vamos a suponer que
está a una distancia 10 de nuestro punto
pivote muy bien y ahora todas las
fuerzas moradas las voy a poner para
aquellas que provoquen una rotación en
la dirección de las manecillas del reloj
verdad en este caso como está del lado
izquierdo esto provoca una rotación de
este estilo verdad y con verde voy a
poner las que generan un movimiento
contrario a las manecillas del reloj
digamos que aquí digamos no sé cómo por
aquí tenemos una fuerza muy grande
50 newtons y digamos que está a una
distancia 8 de nuestro punto pivote y
vamos a poner una última fuerza digamos
pequeña
ahí está digamos que este es de 5
newtons y está a una distancia 4 muy
bien
ahora del lado derecho vamos a obtener
lo siguiente digamos que a una distancia
3 tenemos una fuerza pues más o menos
grande de 10 newtons
10 newtons y esta distancia 3 aunque y
vamos a poner otra fuerza digamos por
acá a distancia 8 digamos de un poco más
derechito
digamos que esta fuerza es de 20 newtons
muy bien y esta está a una distancia 8
pero del lado derecho y si se dan cuenta
como ahora esta flecha verde está del
lado derecho el hecho
ok como es como apunta hacia arriba
provoca justo una rotación en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj lo
mismo o más bien de forma contraria
ocurre para la la flecha amor a la
verdad que provoca una rotación en
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
supongamos que tenemos una fuerza
digamos a una distancia 10
y vamos a quitarlo de ahí tenemos una
fuerza vamos a suponer que va hacia
arriba aunque podría ser lo contrario
que está a una distancia 10 ahora la
pregunta es esta fuerza mística que
ponemos cuánto debe valer para que esté
sube y baja esté balanceado muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos que tomar muy en
cuenta es que todas las fuerzas que
provocan una rotación en dirección de
las manecillas del reloj
esas son una verdad todo el momento el
momento generado por esas fuerzas que
provocan una rotación en la dirección de
las manecillas del reloj vamos a ponerlo
así todo el momento debe ser igual al
momento a almomento net o digamos de
aquellos que van en contra de las
manecillas vamos a escribirlo solo así
muy bien entonces qué es qué es lo que
tenemos que calcular pues tenemos que
calcular cada uno de los momentos en
morado sumarlos y luego sumar los verdes
con el blanco e igualar los entonces
cuál es el momento de esta fuerza x se
esfuerza por distancia esto es 10 por 10
este es el momento de esta primer fuerza
el momento de esta segunda fuerza es 5
por 4 verdad más el momento de esta
tercera fuerza que es 20 por 8 y esto
debe ser igual a quien igual a 50 por 8
cincuenta por ocho más diez por tres más
la fuerza por diez verdad
ahora qué es lo que tenemos del lado
izquierdo tenemos 100 más 20 más 160 son
100 más 20 más 160 y esto debe ser igual
a quien a 50 por 8 que son 400 más 10
por 3 que son 30
10 efe muy bien entonces que es a lo que
llegamos llegamos aquí aquí del lado
izquierdo tenemos 160 más 20 son 180 más
100 son 280 280 debe ser igual debe ser
igual a 400 más 30 que son 430 y este
fue un ejemplo muy muy bueno van a ver
por qué más 10
efe ok entonces quien debe ser bueno
tenemos que 10
efe son 280 menos 430 eso nos da un
número negativo verdad entonces tenemos
si restamos estos dos números que es lo
que nos queda 430 menos 280
150 pero dijimos que eran negativos es
verdad es negativo así que si dividimos
ahora todo entre 10 nos queda que la
fuerza es menos 15 newtons quiere decir
que esta fuerza que originalmente
pusimos hacia arriba en realidad no va
hacia arriba en realidad va en dirección
contraria así que esta fuerza de aquí va
hacia abajo y es de 15 newtons muy bien
entonces este fue un ejemplo muy bueno
muy sencillo espero que haya quedado un
poco más claro de lo que hicimos en el
vídeo anterior ahora vamos a hacer otro
problema digo este tipo de problemas que
voy a hacer solían confundirme cuando yo
estaba aprendiendo todo esto sobre torca
el momento dinámico que es lo mismo y de
este tipo de ejercicios pero pero en
cierto sentido son los más útiles que te
puedas encontrar así que digamos que
tenemos una tabla
vamos a poner un color medio de madera
tenemos aquí esta tabla
y más o menos o digamos que es como una
mesa
ok ahí tienen ustedes esta tabla de
madera y digamos que aquí tenemos esta
está digamos soportada
o hay un soporte hecho por 22 piernas
digamos
más derechistas
es ahí está mucho mejor entonces tenemos
estas dos piernas que soportan a esta
tabla digamos esto es como una especie
de mesa muy bien digamos que esta mesa
tiene una tiene un peso digamos de 20
newtons
ok 20 minutos recuerden que no es lo
mismo peso que más la verdad el peso es
una fuerza debido a la gravedad
terrestre y mientras que la masa es
digamos una forma como de medir la
cantidad de materia que hay en algún
lugar verdad más o menos
y bueno digamos entonces que pongo aquí
mis libros no sé aquí tengo varios
libros libros de variable compleja que
está muy grande
es un libro demasiado grande ok pero
y este digamos que como tiene mucho
contenido tiene un peso de 100 newtons
ok este tiene un peso de 100 newtons
ahora esto por supuesto no se mueve
verdad están bien soporte este libro
mira está bien soportado en esta mesa
pero eso es porque tenemos dos puntos
sobre esta mesa que están soportando el
peso verdad entonces la pregunta que que
hay que hacernos es ver cuánta fuerza
soporta cada una de estas piernas ok
entonces digamos vamos a suponer
15 en este argumento supongan si ustedes
que esta pierna empieza a flaquear
digamos que es débil entonces si la
pierna del lado izquierdo es este es
mucho más resistente mucho más
resistente entonces esta está esta mesa
digamos va a girar de esta forma si es
que esta pierna fallara
de la misma forma digamos no sé si
ustedes le ponen aquí un resorte
entonces esta pierna se empieza a elevar
de esta forma quiere decir con esto
quiero decirles que este punto de aquí
este que estoy enmarcando todavía más
puede ser sin pérdida de generalidad
nuestro punto de rotación es decir sería
como nuestro pivote ok entonces si éste
es nuestro pivote vamos a ver cuánto
cuánta fuerza se ejerce de este lado muy
bien entonces lo que sabemos es que la
los momentos se deben conservar verdad
hay una conservación del momento
y para poder resolver todo este problema
tenemos que dar las distancias verdad
así que vamos a suponer que la distancia
de este eje a donde se encuentra el
centro del libro digamos que es a un
metro muy bien y vamos a suponer que de
aquí al centro de la mesa son dos metros
digamos como el centro es justamente eso
es un centro quiere decir que de aquí de
dónde está el eje de rotación hasta
dónde está la otra pierna hay cuatro
metros muy bien entonces aquí por
supuesto hay una fuerza que va no
sabemos si hacia arriba o hacia abajo
pero ya vimos que eso lo vamos a poder
determinar después hay una fuerza que no
conocemos vamos a llamarle fuerza de la
pierna digamos ok entonces vamos a ver
en qué consiste este problema estas dos
fuerzas la de 100 newtons y la de 20
newtons son fuerzas que van hacia abajo
y que producen una rotación en dirección
de las manecillas del reloj verdad
entonces mientras que la fuerza de la
pierna es una fuerza que va hacia arriba
y ese provoca una rotación en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj
entonces si igualamos los momentos
tendremos
por uno más veinte por 220 por dos que
este es el momento de cada una de estas
fuerzas debe ser igual a cuatro veces
nuestra fuerza de la pierna es decir
aquí que tenemos que 140 es igual a 4
veces la fuerza de la pierna y si
dividimos entre 4 tendremos que la
fuerza de la pierna es 140 entre 4 y
podemos sacar mitad en ambos y tenemos
70 entre 2 que esto es 35 verdad tenemos
que la fuerza de la pierna desde 35
newtons y como esto está en equilibrio
hay una misma fuerza que se ejerce hacia
abajo verdad que es que la soporte
entonces esté desde 35 newtons y ahora
con esto ya podemos determinar cuál es
la fuerza que se encuentra del lado
izquierdo porque estas fuerzas se deben
a anular perdón ya que está todo en
reposo así que si nos fijamos esta
fuerza de aquí
fuerza de aquí que ejerce digamos que va
hacia abajo es de 100 más 20 menos 35
verdad esta fuerza de aquí eso es porque
este lado ya estaba soportando 35
newtons de los 120 que acumulan tanto el
libro como la como la mesa entonces
tendremos 120 120 menos 35 entonces si a
120 le restamos 30 nos dan 90 y si ahora
le restamos 5 esto nos da 85 newtons ok
es esa es la fuerza que tenemos del lado
izquierdo y con esto ya podía ya ya
pudimos resolver el problema de ver cuál
es la fuerza que soporta cada una
cada una de estas piernas de esta mesa
entonces como podrás imaginarte esto es
bastante útil para los ingenieros y los
arquitectos arquitectos que están
dispuestos a construir puentes verdad
porque si uno construye un puente uno
tiene que ir midiendo cuánto puede
soportar cada una
estructuras que va montando a lo largo
de este puente muy bien también a lo
mejor puede ser útil para para los
carpinteros que hagan mesas o muebles o
qué sé yo algunas otras profesiones
ahora también como te darás cuenta la
fuerza del lado izquierdo era mucho más
grande que la del lado derecho esto es
porque el lado izquierdo tiene que
soportar más peso ya que el libro del
que tenía yo aquí sobre la mesa está
mucho más cercano a ese lado como sea
bueno espero que hayas encontrado este
vídeo bastante interesante y espero que
nos veamos en próximos vídeos